sup Instagram just wanted to say hi to
all of my followers I really wanted to
say I appreciate you guys so much for
supporting me amanda bynes is speaking
out for the first time since her
engagement this is also the first time
that she's ever shared a video to her
Instagram wanted to check in let you
know that I'm out to dinner right now
with my friend Kathy who's a student
advisor at that um my college I'm really
looking forward to starting my clothing
line so no mention of the engagement but
an update on her fashion endeavors and
I'm hoping that in the near future it
will be out online so the clip ends
pretty abruptly but take a close look
looks like Amanda might have a second
face tattoo the new one is right above
her eyebrow it's also something we first
saw earlier this week in her newest pick
with fiance Paul Michael now Amanda's
new post and possible new tattoo comes
on the heels of her engagement though et
has exclusively learned that she and
Paul don't live together and her parents
have never met the guy the couple did
meet in a sober living facility about
two months ago and got engaged on
Valentine's Day are you gonna be okay
yes amanda has of course had a wildly
successful career but she's faced some
troubles over the past few years amanda
is currently under conservatorship and
can't actually legally get married
unless a judge and her mom sign off on
the nuptials
amanda has opened up about some of her
past troubles which have included drug
abuse and mental health in 2018 she
talked to paper magazine about addiction
and at the time she talked about the
fashion line but noted she wanted to
return to acting first nineteen
superstar singing sensation chief he
Springs he has spoken with some of
Amanda's former co-stars over the years
about how she's doing
Nick Cannon who she started with on all
that said this five years ago you wrote
this open letter to amanda Bynes oh yeah
yeah I am the biggest Amanda Bynes fan
like
how do you talk to her as of recently I
haven't but I heard she's doing so much
better and that's I mean people when
they're weird when they're dealing with
personal issues sometimes you got to
give him that space yeah and then when
they reach out then that's the time to
do it so she knows and you know I always
to open invite whenever she needs
anything I'm career or even personally
I'm here
I would love a comeback oh yeah we
wanted her we were trying to get her on
wild and I we had to all that reunion
and that's kind of when I knew like okay
she still she's still working on herself
and which is an outstanding thing yeah
and Channing Tatum her she's the man
co-star also had something to say I love
her I'm so happy she's like killing it
again just package back on the right
like it's she's so special and she's
been doing it I mean like I think it's
so impossible when you start at such a
young age like what do you remember most
about that time and that experience
doing everything she was just so alive
like I mean when I say like you never
knew what was going to come out of her
mouth like you she was just I don't know
I haven't seen her in so long above you
we love all the support if you or
someone that you know is struggling with
addiction just remember there is help
out there for all the latest on Amanda
Bynes of course be sure to stick with
all things et until next time I'm Katie
Krause and bye for now
[Music]